a dissertation proposal defense of
Julian Eggar who is a PhD candidate in
the bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine major and as we always do
the candidate defends their proposal and
if acceptable to the committee and and
the rest of the honest doesn't uncover
any major problems they then advance to
do their dissertation work and then
we'll come back some number of months
down the road to defend their
dissertation so Julian received his
bachelor's degree in bioinformatics with
a minor in computer science from the
University of Nebraska Omaha in 2014 and
he has had a variety of other jobs
working as a bioinformatics programmer
at the Omaha Henry Doorly Zoo genetics
department he's also spent some time in
industry as a software engineer at
thermo Fisher and his research interest
is focused on the study of genomics
using RNA sequencing with an emphasis on
alternative splicing in cellular
differentiation and disease so we will
let him get going okay thank you Bill
thank everyone for coming to my proposal
so the title of my proposal is
alternative splicing event signatures of
drug response and AML so just a quick
overview of what I'll be talking about
I'll give a brief background on what AM
L is and what alternative splicing is
and then as I go through my specific
aims you'll hear me discuss kind of an
overarching theme of my project which is
sent around a methodology known as event
based splicing methods and so what is a
cumulative kumea or am L AM L is the
cancer of my low blood cells in which we
have these abnormal mile Brass that
would normally differentiate into
different types of white blood cells
begin to accumulate and the blood and
bone marrow and as these abnormal cells
start to accumulate that leads to a loss
of other types of blood cells like red
blood cells and platelets cells
and that leads to some of the known some
of the nose symptoms of AML including an
ability to fight infection fatigue and
loss of breath and increased bruising
bleeding and so am L there's about
proximate twenty thousand people are
diagnosed in the United States annually
with AML and around ten thousand annual
deaths in the u.s. it's characterized by
a high rate of patient relapse after
clinical remission and it has a very low
five-year survival rate that as you can
see significantly decreases with patient
age so how does ml develop mo develops
through different genetic changes in the
Hamada poetic stem of progenitor stem
cell lineage so if we look at normal
hematopoiesis we have our Ematic wither
stem cells which can either go down the
winning edge and become lymphoid cells
or we can go down an alternate legend
become my load cells in the case of AML
we have different genetic changes that
occur somewhere around the stem cell
area of the lineage or in the progenitor
cells and as the genetic events occur
this leads to these cells becoming
Teaneck cells which the stem cells or
the key make progenitor cells and it's
these abnormal I love the quemic cells
that begin accumulating when not about
ml is that this genetic development at
least this admin design level cells is a
much more rapid development compared to
that of chronic myeloid leukemia so
these different generative ents are
talking about these can be sited genetic
events like different chromosome
abnormalities like translocations and
versions or they can be small genomic
events like mutations so business
mutations or like in Dells and even
further the presence of these different
genetic events have sniffing a
prognostic implications so for instance
this is the European the communit
prognostic system where shows that the
the presence of these different size
exact events or somatic gene mutations
can be used to assess the overall risk
of the different patients and put them
into different risk categories as either
a favorable favorable intermediate or
adverse and additionally new mutation
events continue still continue to be
identified in AML patients and many
these show prognostic implications and
this has led to the development of new
targeted therapies to address these
different types of mutations however a
challenge of AML therapy development is
that the mutational landscape is highly
heterogeneous and complex where patients
can Harbor a variety of different
mutations and combinations of across
thousands of genes and the presence of
these different combinations can lead to
a varying degree in drug response across
the different AML patients in addition
to the silo genetic advance and
mutations that I discussed earlier it's
also known that there are different
alternative splicing events that are
significant AML for instance there's
splicing events that are found that are
differentiated between normal patients
and a male patients some of these are
recurrent splicing events that are seen
through at least a significant portion
of AML patients but just like the
different side of genetic and gene
mutation events it's a very
heterogeneous landscape where patients
can Harbor different combinations of
aberrant splicing events and like I said
a lot of these have different prognosis
implications including the
aggressiveness that can be associated
with drug resistance relapse and
survival so what is Army what is
alternative splicing
so in RNA splicing when during gene
expression during expression we have a
pre mRNA transcripts
and in this pre mRNA we have certain
regions known as introns which are
introns which are removed and the
remaining regions known as exons are
left in and these are spliced together
to form the final mature mRNA product
and then this mRNA is eventually
translated into a functional protein so
with alternative splicing we can
actually use different combinations of
these exonic regions and this allows a
single gene to produce multiple mature
mRNA transcripts and these mature mRNA
transcripts could potentially translate
into fully functional proteins with
differing functionalities between them
all from a single gene and so there's
kind of different ways to categorize the
different types of splicing so we do
this in the form of alternative splicing
events which focuses on the patterns
this place
so for instance we can have just a
simple exon skipping event where once
transcript will include a particular
exon another transcript and alternative
transcript would skip the exon there not
include exon but we can have other types
of events as well where we can have
actual we can use or partially use
different exons some kind of alternative
splice sites where we use all the the
exon or we only use part of the exon but
you also have a special case of exon
skipping events where the exons are
skipped in a mutually exclusive manner
where one transcript will only contain
one or the other exon we can also have
intron retention events where actually
the entire intronic region that would
normally be spliced out is completely
retained within the final mRNA
transcripts and we can also categorize
these spices as in terms of the
alternative you know which is the first
exon use and which is the first laksa
which is the last exon using our
transcript but we can also have go
beyond just basic splicing events and
this will kind of be significant as I go
through my talk where we can have
multiple skip we kind of skipping back
from multiple exons at once so this is
known as exons cluster skipping
essentially we can also have compound
events where we might have more than one
basic event compound into a single event
for instance we could have a particular
event could include or exclude skipping
while also including or excluding
different five prime to three prime
splice sites has also been shown that
some of these splicing events they're
tightly regulated in normal biology but
they are weather deregulated they can
lead to different disease and cancer and
specifically the case of cancer it's
been shown that the expression of these
different splicing events can have an
impact on drug resistance so for
instance this di M gene we have this
exon skipping event in normal biology
both of these events are typically
expressed in a regulated manner but it's
been shown that if there's an increase
in the expression of the skipped exon
version of the splice variant that
increase in expression is associated
with resistance to tyrosine kinase
inhibitors in this case this is an
example in chronic myeloid leukemia
and so this leads me to my central
hypothesis for my project which is that
therapeutic resistance in AML can be
partially characterized by the
expression of distinct splice variants
and transcript and wide coordination the
splicing events influences response to
treatment and so before I get into my
specific aims I'd like to talk about the
data set they'll be using and so the
data I'm using is actually derived from
the beat AML program which is a crab of
research program led here by OHSU that
involves multiple universities and
multiple pharmaceutical companies and
especially the largest today at a male
patient data set and what's so
significant about this data set is that
it involves all different kinds of data
it not only has a clinical data about
the patients but it also includes
cytogenetics data
mutation data from whole exome
sequencing expression data so we can
look at gene expression from RNA
sequencing and it also has drug response
for multiple drug types and just to kind
of summarize what and actually just this
last just last year they published a
paper as sort of a first insight of
looking into the functional genomic
landscape of this data and just to kind
of summarize some of the key things that
they did that they were looking at
associations of mutation status and gene
expression and looking at the
associations of those genetic events in
terms of drug response so this is a
circle plot that shows different
mutation all these different genetic
events across the entire transcript down
label by different chromosome label by
chromosome and the inner part of the
circle we can see the different AML
chromosomal rearrangements and then this
first inner circle here each dot
represents a particular mutation that
was found to be highly associated with
drug response and for any of these
different inhibitors and then the next
circle out these are genes so this
represents genes that were significantly
different to the expressed between
resistant and sensitive patients so
looking more at the data set from this
that I'll be using
I'll be using the RNA sequencing data as
well as the drug response values and so
411 of patients of that cohort have RNA
sequencing samples derived from either
peripheral blood or bone marrow tissue
this is just a hierarchical clustering
and a heat map showing the most variable
Express genes so this is gene expression
this is expression at the gene level
I'll be doing my project after the
splicing level and I'll discuss on doing
that here in a minute and then I'll be
using the drug the drug response values
like I said so this is a high school
clustering of the different drugs for
all the different hitters across the
patients and so my first specific aim is
to identify splicing event Express the
signatures of drug response and AML
using a random forest model
so what terrain of forest ran of forest
is a supervised learning algorithm and
it's actually an in Samba method and
that it involves a collection of
decision trees which each tree is
actually given a vote and predicting the
outcome for a particular observation so
to build arena forests we build a
decision tree one at a time in this
particular example this is a building of
a decision tree this is sort of
arbitrary example where we're predicting
relapse and non relapse using gene
expression data and so when we build
each tree what we do is we take a random
sub sample about of our observations and
then we leave an out of bag sample to
assess the accuracy of our of each tree
and as we build these tree what we do is
we take our training sample and we also
we also take I've forgot to mention that
we take a random sub sample of all of
our features as well and we choose from
that random sample of features the best
feature that can separate our
observations into one of our two
possible outcomes and we do this
iteratively through so many iterations
until a certain point where we keep
choosing the the feature that best
separates separates the observation so
in this case non non relapse and relapse
and we keep doing that to build each
tree and then after we've done this for
you know for example 10,000 trees we
build our forest and then each like I
mention each tree in our forest gets a
vote and predicting the overall outcome
and so an important point and this is
kind of why I'm looking at utilizing a
random forest is that arena for us
actually provides a variable importance
measure and so for each tree that we
built if we see variables or features
that were frequently chosen or others
the more frequently chosen features will
be given a higher variable importance
and so this is this is one thing I'm
going to use for this for addressing the
specific aim
so just kind of a use case of example
this is a paper where they're looking at
resistance and sensitivity in multi
myeloma where they used a random forest
approach to identify a 42 gene
expression signature of drug response
and so this is just a heat map of
showing the the signature that they
produce from the random forest procedure
and this just shows the the genes that
represent that gene expression signature
and then it shows how the genes are
upregulated and downregulated in either
sensitive or resistance for this is a
proteome inhibitor so how do I do this
at the splicing level there's different
ways to quantify alternative splicing
and I'll be using this event based
approach where we focus on these
localized alternative events that I
mentioned earlier and what we do is we
represent the expression as the relative
inclusion of the of each event and I'll
discuss this here a little bit more in a
second and this allows us to quantify
quantify alternate splicing without the
complexity issues of train a full-length
transcript assembly and estimation which
is a limitation of short read RNA
sequencing so how do we do this
so what we do is we isolate patterns of
splicing from either gene annotations or
read alignments so right here we're
looking at this is a single gene in
which we can have for alternatively
spliced transcripts each with their own
sort of set of exon structures here we
also have a reference genome and are
aligned reads from a particular data set
and so we isolate out the different
events in this case this is a skipped
exon event that was found in our
annotation so this is a known event and
then we collapse that event down into it
this sort of single unit that represents
the binary outcome over possible
splicing event and then we quantify
using using our reads and we quantify it
using a metric known as % spliced in
which represents the relative inclusion
of one event in this case the the skip
dice on the inclusion of the skips exon
over the total expression of both
possible outcomes and so this allows us
to quantify splicing without having to
try and quantify the expression of all
these individuals transcripts which is
an issue be considering our read size
and the fact that many of these reads
could actually belong to multiple
transcripts because they they share all
or part of the exons
and so kind of an overall wealth of the
specific game so for each drug I'll
first filter splicing events using some
sort of pre filtering method for
instance I could flip her away the lease
variable splicing events in terms of
their prayer psi and then from those
filtered events I would build a random
forest mama predicting drug response so
for instance I would use I could use a
regression for us that predicts the drug
response variable which is represented
as the area under the curve from the
ex-vivo drug response assay and then
from there identify using the variable
importance I would identify significant
splicing events as the signatures for
each drug an alternate approach though
that I'm looking at using is actually a
classification for us where and this is
kind of based off what they did in the
beat AML paper they took the top 20 and
by the top and bottom 20 percent in
terms of drug response and sort of pre
labeled those as either sensitive or
resistant and in that case what I would
do is I would pre label those and
actually build a classification for us
for predicting either sensitive
sensitivity or resistance and in the
same effort I would then find my
significant splicing events to represent
each drug some considerations though for
wrong this will certainly be done
through a cross-validation framework
another thing is the pre filtering
events I mentioned one possibility I
could do is looking at variance another
thing I could do also like in the case
of the classification model if the
variance doesn't filter the defense down
enough keep in mind that for each gene
we could actually have multiple events
maybe dozens of events so there could be
thousand events thousands of events that
we'd be putting into her model we could
pretty filter based on some sort of
differential expression cutoff and this
gets to be differential splicing where
we could include events that have for
instance a change in psi of maybe 5%
another consideration is sample size so
I mentioned that there was 363 patient
samples that have rna-seq and drug
response what for these 122 inhibitors
however not every patient has a drug
response for every every inhibitor so
some of these for some of the drugs we
may actually have a too small of the
sample size to do something like
stratifying the the page
samples into either sensitivity
resistance but the expected outcome as I
mentioned is a splicing event expression
profile for each drug where for instance
we might have for a particular drug
there may be a particular skip to exon
where the inclusion of that exon the
expression of the of the included
version is upregulated in the
sensitivity patients and then the
exclusion version is upregulated in the
resistant patients and it's also
important to point out that the outcome
of this aim will give us a set of
independent splicing events so if we
look more into transcriptional
regulation it's actually a high
convention it's a highly coordinated
process but even further gene expression
changes or splice variant expression
changes they don't occur independently
we tend to have multiple genes operating
interacting with in cellular pathways so
an example of this is the seller
differentiation program there is
epithelium a second transition or EMT in
which these epithelial cells go through
a transition process and become these MS
ECMO itself what this with a different
phenotype and this transition is driven
by coordinated changes of different
genes so there we have dozens of genes
that are upregulated and regulated in
the coordinated fashion to drive EMT so
a way that we can study this this sort
of coordination of regulation is using
gene co-expression networks where we can
study gene expression now on a systems
level and not just look at differential
expression at the individual gene level
and so gene pool expression networks
that allow us to characterize Co
expression patterns between genes and we
can study how and with whom that the
genes interacts we've also identified
clusters or neighborhoods of genes that
are driving a particular phenotype by
doing that we can look at the biological
functions and the pathways that those
genes may be involved in it's important
to point out that in order to do this
we're using code expression networks
under a key assumption and that groups
of highly correlated genes cooperate
with the related pathways and functions
so bringing up the EMT example again not
on not only is EMT driven by four main
changes in gene expression but is also
driven by coordinated changes and an
expression of distinct splice variants
so how can we study coordinated splicing
on a systems level and so there's been
different approaches to look at a
network view of splicing one of which is
a transcript co-expression network where
our nodes or transcripts and we look at
the correlation of the transcript
expression across samples in order to do
this though we have to assemble and
estimate the abundance of full-length
transcripts and this is a time an issue
with short reads because we have these
certain reads that are ambiguous into in
terms of which transcript that it
originated from so this means that when
we have our expression for each
transcript we're using a statistical
model to estimate that expression and so
a cue limitation and and using a
transcript network is we could have an
incorrect assembly step and we can also
have incorrect estimations for the
expression of those transcripts so a way
that we can alleviate that complexity is
we could do an exon co-expression
network or now our nodes or exons and
we're looking at the correlation of exon
expression across samples and to do this
what we do is we create a unionize set
of exons where we create this sort of
overlapping set from all of our epsilon
structures from all of our transcripts
and then we quantify the expression of
those exons we build a net worth
measuring the correlation of the exon
expression however an alternative
approach to doing this is rather than
quantifying the total expression of each
exon we could quantify the relative
expression of each exon and measure and
now measure the correlations of the
relative exon expression where it's the
relative the exon expression relative
the total expression of the gene and so
if we do this we can see that the spirts
to resemble that of like an exon
skipping network because we're doing
relative inclusion and so an example of
this was this paper by sebastian at all
last year where they didn't they did an
exon network of developing mouse cortex
and rather than looking at total
expression they looked at relative
relative inclusion of the exon
expression and they did this to look at
developed developing Mouse cortex using
a time series RNA suck data and they're
able to identify clusters of exons of
using the relative expression and
identified this these sort of temporal
clusters of exons going through changes
through the developmental program like
either
early switch pattern or a late switch
pattern so yes so as I mentioned this
approach kind of allows you to somewhat
look at like a like an exon skipping
Network so going further with exon with
exon skipping if we actually look at the
different types of splicing events that
occur in different genomes we can see in
the case of humans that exon skipping is
the most common form of alternative
splicing but even then it still only
represents about half of the possible
splice events that we see in humans if
we go down in the case a mouse which is
what they looked at we can see that
we're even closer and now to only
represent about 40% of the possible
splice events that work that we would be
possible to occur and then we go in
different species all the way down to
plants we can actually see that exon
skipping events are actually the least
common splicing events in plants and so
if we're building network based on the
relative inclusion of exons we actually
wouldn't be representing very much of
our genome if we stick with humans
though but we addressed the case of
cancer in humans it's actually well
known that we actually have a increase
in non skipped exon events where we have
these sort of cancer specific splice
events this data is from a study where
they looked at the different types of
splicing events across different cancer
types and one thing they show is that
they have a sort of a decrease in the
total ratio of skipped up exon events
compared to all the other events and
another thing that that's been that
we've been seeing in cancer is that we
actually have an increase in these in
shock and trauma retention events and so
yeah just again like in the case of an
owl or some of the other cancers if we
were to build a network based on just X
on inclusion levels we'd still only be
representing maybe half of the possible
splicing events and this data actually
only includes the most basic splicing
events it doesn't include any of the
complex events that are actually common
that we commonly seen in cancer and so
with that said if we look at some of
these cancer specific splicing events we
can see we you know we do have exon
skipping events but we do have these
other events that aren't just exon
skipping where we might have this exon
skipping cluster that it might be
significant to a particular drug
response and a particular cancer so if
we wanted to do a network approach to
look at coordinated splicing it'd be
more beneficial to
actually have the network that looks at
the expression of the specific variants
that are known to happen in cancer
rather than just looking at the relative
inclusion of these individual exons and
so this leads me to my second specific
aim which is to develop an event-based
splicing Network approach to study the
co-expression ansel Co expression of
alternative splicing events and identify
and annotate potential splicing Network
modules associated with drug response in
AML so how I'm going to do this so if we
recall the event based splicing method
where we quantify splicing and form
these localized splicing events we've
quantified these events for all the
events that we can find across all of
our samples and then we build a
correlation network using the the
quantified percent splice and other
splicing transformer samples and so to
do this we'd use a similarity measure
just like other Co expression networks
the exact similar slim already measured
that will work for the splicing of that
case is something that I don't actually
know so this is something that I'll have
to evaluate as I work on this project
but essentially what we do is then we
would have a network where each node of
our network represents a particular
event from a particular gene and each
edge is a weighted as representing the
correlation between those events based
on our sample expression and then so in
a network analysis what we want to do is
run a cluster of these of these events
to group highly related splicing events
and form modules that might be driving
their phenotype and so we can use some
sort of clustering approach and there's
many of these cluttering approaches so
again just like the network development
this is something that I'll have to
evaluate so I'd have to evaluate the
clustering steps and the different
parameters involved one way we can sort
of evaluate how well our clustering data
is we can use module statistics for
instance we can play an intro module
instrument of density we're to look at
how it tightly connected are the each
node within our module and also inner
module separ bility statistics or we can
see how separated all the modules from
each other as a means of evaluating our
clustering procedure and the parameters
that we used so what this does is we
actually essentially now form a module
in network we can now look at the
relationships between modules and rather
just and
notes and so one thing that we can do is
we can use a what's known as the
eigenvector of the module which would
spatially summarize the expression of
the module as a single value and then we
can use this information for and
basically a new correlation network or
now we can look at the correlations
between different modules and if we see
highly correlated modules it could mean
that we may have interacting pathways
but we could also use it to further
refine our network and maybe merge our
modules for instance if they're highly
correlated that may mean that they're
poorly defined and they should actually
be merged to make a better module so if
we take a step back and sort of take a
high level view of co-expression
networks and why we're clustering data
in the modules this is actually a data
reduction technique it alleviates the
multiple testing problem and from a
biological standpoint this makes sense
because phenotypes are driven by
coordinated changes of genes all
interacting within similar pathways and
by doing this we can now focus in on
those interacting genes or in this case
splicing events and focus on the
pathways that they're involved in and
what's driving that particular phenotype
and we can identify the most central
components of those particular modules
and in order to find so once after we
close from the modules we'd want to find
significant modules that would be
driving our particular phenotype in this
case of the drug response for the
different inhibitors so we get for
instance we could now include the
correlation of drug response with the
module eigenvector and look at the trait
of interest that way to identify which
module is most significant to our trait
of interest another extension that's
something that I want to do is also
integrate the expression of regulatory
genes so for instance splicing factor
genes are genes that regulate the
splicing of hundreds and thousands of
other genes and so we can integrate the
total gene expression of these splicing
factors so once we identify significant
spicy modules we can look at what are
the splicing factors that are regulating
the splicing events driving this
particular phenotype we've also taken up
more and after identifying the
significant module we can take a more
kind of zoomed in approach where we can
actually look at the components of that
significant module one way we can
identify key splicing events from the
splicing module is to look at for
instance module memberships and the ones
that are most highly correlated to
eigenvector we can also look at at work
all
hub node so the most centrally located
nodes or the nodes that have the highest
intra modular connectivity these tend to
be the most important notes and maybe
the most biologically meaningful for
what's driving the overall module
another approach for looking at keys you
know in terms of gene networks in this
case spice networks working identify
maybe significant splicing events is
what's known as differential
co-expression and this is where we
actually compared networks across
different conditions so if we identify
something a module and like we could
what we could do and this will depend on
the sample size we could build a
consensus network where we identify some
of the module and then we could compare
that network in this sensitive and
resistant across the sensitive samples
and the resistance samples and have
separate networks and look at changes in
the correlations of the nodes and we
find for instance a node that is strong
differential connectivity or
differential correlations that may be a
potential node of interest so this this
has actually been shown to be a means of
identifying like at least in the case of
Jenin networks identify genes that
aren't necessarily differentially
expressed but can still be significant
based on differential connectivity after
kind of doing all this it's important to
validate a network so there's kind of
different methods I'll be looking at in
terms of validating my network one such
approach that's commonly used validating
a network is module preservation
statistics where if you build a network
based on a particular data set you try
to evaluate it by building another
network an external data set and looking
to see how well your modules are
preserved across the data set another
method is you could use random
permutations where you actually randomly
permit permute the the samples in your
network and do different random
combinations of the expression values
and what you can do here is then you can
see that the network statistics that you
identify from their network are
significant like you could create an
empirical p-value to show that those
particular statistics are actually
significant and not something that you
just see by chance another way that I'm
actually looking at validating it though
just the overall methodology is to do an
external data set that's known in terms
of the splice Network so I mentioned
this exon network of developing mouse
cortex
these sort of sand pearls
splicing patterns are actually well
known and has been well studied and
other developmental programs including
the ent example that he gave earlier so
one thing I'm looking at doing is
building my network which would include
skeptic saws but all the other splicing
events is to test it on this data set
and see if I can you know not get the
exact same modules but see if I could
recapitulate some of the same temporal
splicing patterns that I would expect to
see in the developmental program there
are some considerations of potential
pitfalls the pitfalls of this project
one thing that's actually really
interesting that I'm going to be looking
at is splice events of the same gene and
so one thing to think about is like do
we treat I mentioned how a single game
can have multiple splicing events do we
treat a splicing event that occurs from
the same gene for instance the two blue
events are from one gene and this green
event is a separate gene do we treat
those events the same as we would for
events of the other gene we might assume
that all the events of that belong to
the same gene might always be highly
correlated we don't know if that's
something I'm gonna look at so a
possible solution if we don't want to
bias our network that way is to maybe
remove any sort of any of the edges
between same gene events and what you
would hope is is if they are significant
for instance for in a significant module
if they are highly correlated with
another event from another gene the fact
that they're both correlated with the
other gene hopefully that would still
sustain the module event they're both
significant we would find that innocent
if your module another approach might be
to actually aggregate the events to the
gene level where we actually look at the
correlation from at the genes
perspective based on the overall events
and so this is something that's actually
been done for exons for a gene an exon
level gene network where we at were they
aggregate of the exon level expression
to the gene level and this might be some
option to avoid this bias is by
aggregating the events to the gene level
another big issue with this data set
though is their headers maybe issue and
that we can have templars we have
different artifacts or batch effects
these can be technical artifacts
including our innate quality or library
prep rendering where it was sequence and
also biological artifacts that
expect to see in the data set like this
where we can have changes in expression
or heterogeneity nor expression based on
age gender the different disease
subtypes there's different subtypes of
AML and another key one here is tissue
source I mentioned earlier that the data
is actually derived from either
peripheral blood or bone marrow tissue
and we know that we have tissue specific
gene expression and tissue specific
splicing very expression so this is
something I have to deal with so for
instance here's an example where we have
gene expression that's confounded by
these potential artifacts and it shows
that we now have spurious signals and
our correlation network so the idea is
to have a method and this is been looked
at in this case this is an example of
trying to use the principal components
where we identified the prints of
components that best explained
variability to these confounders and try
to regress out that variability without
regressing out the signal for the
phenotype of interest and then actually
having true signals so this is something
that it's really important I'm gonna
have to look at it for this project so
just a summarize my project as a whole
so the first aim is gonna identify
independent splicing events for
sensitive or resistant and now well my
second aim is going to be able to
characterize meknes mechanisms of
coordinated splicing promoting
therapeutic resistance but both of these
aims although independent they're
actually highly related and that both of
which will find splicing event
signatures of drug response or potential
splicing event signatures and this may
have hopefully potential therapeutic
implications in terms of aberrant
splicing and its role in a ml drug
response and also this splicing of that
Network I believe is a new methodology
to look at coordinated splicing beyond
just cancer it can look at look at
corneas placing other diseases and other
aspects of biology so with that I'd like
to thank my dissertation Advisory
Committee the D my students faculty and
staff and a knowledge meant to my NLM
training grant ok she's asking me to do
if I plan on doing any further subtyping
a sub grouping based on right the so the
flip 3 internal tandem duplication right
do you mean in terms of like like
looking at the splice events separately
for the positive and negative that's
actually another thing I might look at
doing so looking at more of like a
homogeneous group and seeing how that if
that maybe helps because that could also
affect my results necessarily associate
you know if I only did in the positive
case but the despise events there and
kind of seen how they change across
groups does that kind of answer your
question because also you know there's
also dealer Jeannette like some types of
ammo I think also kind of would depend
on like sample size too
right right absolutely yeah yeah
actually I do plan on doing that right
excited yeah definitely like for
instance if I can find it like a
significant splicing module I'd like to
see the co-occurrence with the the other
mutation so that's all I did yeah
exactly right that's my life
that's my plan thank you
that's a good question um ideally I
think I think so she's asking like what
are the there's different seminary
measures like different correlation
measures so I'll have to i'll have to
sort of evaluate how well this
correlation measures work I think to do
that I'd have to look at you know
different network statistics I'd have to
look at like how you know like the
connective like the connectivity of the
network how maybe how well-preserved I
could maybe do a cross validation
technique to see and do that to kind of
assess the the overall network structure
and maybe perhaps like split an idea
maybe they actually split the data up to
see how well if I pick up for instance a
particular similarity measure how well
that's like represented across multiple
data sets I think again data side coming
suicides but exactly how I'm going to
assess each measure I think I don't
completely know the answer right now but
that's a huge part of my of my second
aim though actually
yeah that's a good question right
there's a lot of things that we do know
from that initial analysis um I
definitely yeah and that kind of goes
back to Rory was saying I'd like to kind
of integrate that with the known data to
see how well that sort of recapitulates
things in terms of so you mentioned like
with the co-expression analysis like get
right right right doesn't it okay that's
an interesting point so I can't least
maybe talk about with like an example so
one of the most mutated genes in the
data set was a particular splicing
factor for instance so it may not be
that if that one is highly associated
with the drug response it may not be
that the splicing events are what are
causing tartar sauce
it may be contributing to the change in
drug response but it could go back to
the the splicing regulator which is
highly mutated is causing the aberrant
regulation of the splicing in this and
so really that that is kind of the
overall kind of goal is to kind of bring
and displacing a layer of it but I'm not
I don't necessarily think that that
there's something aware of I don't know
so I think of the individual splicing
events maybe the most as I can point to
it but it may actually explain some of
the mechanisms that are leading to
different changes and drug response
across the dataset
a bomb right exactly
yeah um that I don't completely know I I
hope the splicing event methods can
alleviate some of that but yeah that is
an issue so the the data set is it's
relatively small I did the prelim rain
Alice to show that it was least the
Junction's world could be well covered
but I did something I'll have to
actually assess the quality I think one
thing I'll kind of have to do it I think
will be important in the exploratory
data analysis to actually look at all
the data in the samples and to see kind
of the overall coverages to see if
there's any moon if I could maybe detect
any bias and I should yeah and that
actually that's another interesting
component is to actually look at the
length of the exons if I find anything
significant to see if maybe that's a
contributing factor to why it's showing
up significant and maybe causing some
sort of bias in my analysis but yeah
that's a great point right yeah
absolutely
uh worming integrating the results right
right and then integrating that with the
second name uh certainly so one thing I
will be doing is I'd like to see if
there's overlap with with the splicing
modules so if there's a and you hope
that there would be if I do find for
since a cluster of splicing events you
would hope that some of those would
actually contain some of the significant
splicing events that I found so that
does something I would to do see if that
if they're over-represented in that
module right right that I'm not exactly
sure what that threshold how I would do
it but yeah there would be probably be
some sort of threshold or and then I'll
also use a holdout validation test but
yeah that does something I'm thinking
about is what would actually be the
threshold for the most important
variants that would then represent the
signature that's a good question I guess
the random forest doesn't work um well
my initial approach before that was to
just do a multiple hypothesis testing
approach so that that could be a way is
to actually just go forward and do a
differential splicing analysis I could
potentially though look into evaluating
a different learning model to doing that
but yeah I do consider that it could end
up being that I don't end up using a
random forest depend depending how
things go yeah
sure sure right they are completely
[Music]
right to identify the signature no
outside of the validation test or right
how do I test the right right sure sure
exactly how I'm gonna do that I don't
know exactly
specifically how I'm gonna do that but
definitely whether that's something I
have to do
no more questions
okay
[Applause]